okay today I am going to take a few
minutes to tell you about a company
called asteroid limited who has
sponsored this video and I'm going to
discuss some of the big ideas that they
have in the realm of space exploration
and what they're doing to try to enable
people to stake claims on celestial
bodies in our solar system as our
ability to explore those celestial
bodies rapidly advances what they're
doing is pretty novel and bold which is
what makes it experimental but it's also
what makes it fascinating at the same
time the fact that we've not seen
anything like this attempted before
what asteroid limited is mostly dealing
with is the concept of asteroid mining I
recently recommended on the show a great
sci-fi book by Daniel Suarez about
asteroid mining and asteroid mining is
the act of extracting raw materials from
asteroids of course an asteroid being
more or less anything that's orbiting
the Sun that isn't a planet or a comet
they can be as big as 600 miles across
and they very commonly pass by earth
just tens of thousands of miles away and
in 2019 alone so far six asteroids have
come within 50,000 miles of the earth
one asteroid earlier this year actually
came within ninety four hundred miles of
the earth just for perspective the earth
itself is about seventy nine hundred
miles in diameter so we're not talking
about something passing by that far at
all
it's also the consensus that we on earth
will most likely run out of our
important industrial metals sometime in
the next sixty or so years metals like
zinc lead gold copper we already have a
space exploration industry that's worth
hundreds of billions of dollars and lots
of experts are speculating that we might
be about a decade or two away from
technology to mine asteroids for metals
and that could be necessary if we want
to sustain our industrial activity and
technological development here on earth
at the current level whether we should
for moral or sustainability reasons is a
different question but this is sort of a
mathematical
reality so there would be potential for
aerospace companies who are able to
develop spaceflight technology necessary
to do this and it's undoubtedly one of
their motivations right now
now really no one at this point is
saying that asteroid mining will never
happen we seem to know that it's coming
it's more a matter of when and how we
approach it and how are we going to
figure out who is entitled to lay a
claim to asteroids for ownership right
now NASA estimates our suggests that all
of the asteroids in the solar system
most of which reside in the asteroid
belt between Mars and Jupiter are worth
about 700 quintillion dollars to humans
that's about a hundred billion dollars
of value per person currently on earth
and because most of the solar systems
asteroids are in this belt which is
relatively close to Earth it's realistic
that we'd have the capability of
unlocking at least some of that value
within the current century now there are
some established documents that governs
some of this ownership which we've
already talked about on the show before
you've got the Outer Space Treaty of
1967 that was signed by a hundred and
thirty-two countries no government
nation or state can claim sovereignty of
outer space and celestial bodies like
asteroids the premise around asteroid
limited is that individuals in the
private general public should have the
right to claim the future mining rights
of asteroids today and that it should be
done democratically and that the big
space industry corporations shouldn't be
the only beneficiaries of this just
mind-blowing amount of value resources
and wealth that could come that will
come from mining asteroids asteroid
limited wants us to think about this
being analogous to the internet the
internet itself is owned by no-one but
we can claim dot-com domains you would
have been smart to claim certain domain
in the late 90s and early 2000s because
they would have accumulated a lot of
long-term value but how would someone
stake a claim to an asteroid where would
the records be kept
how are the claims validated these are
the problems that that asteroid limited
wants to solve their answer is
blockchain asteroid limited sees itself
as modeling this process after I can ICA
and and that's the organization that
maintains the databases to facilitate
allocating internet namespaces like
domains the asteroid limited blockchain
would be immutable it's a decentralized
ledger that would store the claims there
are 600,000 asteroids in the solar
system that have already been identified
and catalogued and you could codify them
in this blockchain ledger the asteroid
limited smart contract would enable a
cryptocurrency called aster coins which
could be used to buy and sell these
claims and here are the specifics of how
it would work a person would obtain
what's called a block claim from
asteroid limited which will keep within
the asteroid limited blockchain
ecosystem the record of your claim to
the future mining rights of the asteroid
the block claim is a proprietary
mechanism to the Aster coin ecosystem
and the idea is that the ecosystems
cryptocurrency the Aster coin would be
one of the first self-sustaining kryptos
in contrast to something like Bitcoin
which merely functions as virtual gold
or an asset that can be held and
converted back into fiat as needed
asteroid limited believes that the block
claim economy would operate more like a
fiat currency where value is judged
based on the buying power of the
currency the cost of one block claim
registration will be fixed to one aster
coin regardless of the value of the
Aster coin when it was obtained in the
market once the Aster coin is collected
as payment it would then cycle back into
the market through asteroid limited
Treasury so every block
block lane registration is secured by an
aster coin on asteroid limited aetherium
blockchain which is what would promote
the regular usage and liquidity and
growth of aster coin as a currency at
least that's the goal the idea would be
that as space exploration grows so would
the value of a stroke Oien we would have
immediate liquidity through consistent
registrations of blocked claims but the
real potential would be in the
possibility of aster coin continuing to
be circulated long term right now the
more than 600,000 identified asteroids
in the solar system are valued by what's
called spectral analysis which takes
into account the composition of the
asteroid it's mining attributes its
trajectory and distance from the earth
at different future points in time upon
the launch of the block claim ledger
each asteroids value would be
apportioned into a certain number of
block claim tokens each token token
representing 1 million u.s. dollars of
value with each individual block claim
at a price of one aster coin per claim
so for example I think this is best
illuminated via an example if you have
an asteroid that has 82 billion dollars
of estimated value these are actually
not unrealistic numbers for the value of
an asteroids contents and a block claim
is valued at 1 million dollars that
asteroid would have a total of 82,000
block claim tokens available for
registration each of those block claim
tokens is a fractional mathematical
representation of an asteroid expressed
as a percentage of the total claim over
time as the asteroid Ledger evolves
valuation modeling of the claim would
increase based on the number of claims
that are left on that asteroid its
proximity to earth the market value of
its composition which of course would be
affected by the prices of precious
metals here on earth and this would
create a sort of natural demand for
certain asteroids which are more viable
to mine on the basis of their
characteristics so once a block claim is
registered a claim will be identified
and stored in an immune
record cryptographically secured in the
blockchain via that block claim token
and the value of the block camp claim
could be tracked via asteroid Limited's
online platform and their registration
data set the asteroid block claim
exchange would allow individual block
claims to be traded and exchanged in an
online marketplace through potential
mining coops that are established by
claimants as well the goal would be to
position the Aster token as a
transactional currency currency both
presently through the block claim
mechanism as well as in the future were
it to become the digital currency of
mining asteroids the block claim
mechanism would closely parallel the
registry that I can use is to register
internet don't domains on the block
claim platform asteroid limited will
provide a lookup table which they call a
who claim for the public recording of
claims and the provision of private
prohibitions when desired by the
claimant for a small fee the lookup
table would include data like the
asteroids name the type its distance
from Earth its my noble value the
diameter its composition the registered
block claim value the date the block
claim was created the expiration date
for the registrar the names of any
resellers right now the idea is that
each aster token has an intrinsic value
of about a thousand US dollars due to
the 200 billion dollars worth of block
claims that would be held in reserve by
asteroid limited through their
registration of 200 thousand block
claims following the launch of the
platform as asteroid limited sees it
aster coin would then have a life beyond
the IC o---- unlike many tokens being
created through AI cos these days
because aster coins will be the only
supported cryptocurrency for making
block claims as we speak about what
asteroid limited is working on they are
working on the completion of the
asteroid block claim ecosystem
development in order to launch that
claim platform there's an iOS and an
Android mobile app which will be
deployed the goal of those is to make
the claim registration process
just easier for people this is in
development as well this is a very
ambitious project it won't be without
many challenges and hurdles many of
which may even be unforeseen at this
point but they're dealing with a problem
that may very well be something we have
to deal with soon asteroid mining seems
to be the direction we're heading in
it's what people bring up in just about
any conversation about finite metal
resources on earth and how we're going
to deal with it and undoubtedly we will
need to put in place ways of figuring
out and organizing the ownership of
territory and assets that exist beyond
Earth at this point doing something like
this on blockchain it seems like as
viable an option as any other it'll
require a high level of acceptance and
adoption in order to succeed but that's
the case with almost any project that
works this way I really enjoyed learning
about asteroid limited and everything
they're doing and I want to thank them
for sponsoring this video I'll be doing
another video about the project pretty
soon we're all go deeper into how it all
works and in the meantime I encourage
you to check out the project for
yourself go to asteroid Ltd calm I've
also put a link right underneath this
video and of course no financial
suggestions of any kind are being made
by me in this video
anything that is a decision that you're
making about your money you should do
your due diligence and I am NOT
purporting to give anybody advice about
what to do